I mean good for you good for you oh
thanks man thanks I think that's an aw
I'm so happy because I know how hard you
worked I mean I saw all the shows even
SMA was like one of the beginning things
and then all the little guest stars you
did and even up to like Supergirl and
Titan or uh Legends of tomorrow and all
these other things you did it's like you
work and you work and you know that you
believe in yourself and you go I'm
bigger than what I'm being offered I'm
bigger than this and you know it and the
people represent you know it but you're
like no you don't understand it I I I've
had those feelings and then when you
suddenly get validated for me it's it's
like it's almost like your dad who never
says any says hey I'm proud of you it's
like it just validates everything you've
been thinking and it's such it's a
beautiful thing and it's it's welld
deserved it is a thank you but you know
what's funny clowns buddy is a beautiful
thing I am you are you're hilarious um
you know the
secret
to getting to that place for
me
was
realizing I am bigger than my career not
in in egotistical way but right I am
more than just my
career I had this we we may have dabbled
in this last time we spoke but I had
this moment of existential crisis where
I had to asked myself honest questions
about who I was and where my identity
lied in my life and at the time it was
in Ambitions it was in material things I
had been making a lot of money and I was
surrounding myself with things that made
me feel like you know created the
illusion of
success um success in the world's eyes
and my career was my
fixation and it was when I
decided
I'm more than my career what if my
career were to disappear tomorrow it
happens to people all the time in our
business you're like what happened to
that guy they were the one they were the
star they were out front and now they're
what like working at Starbucks nothing
wrong with that you know but but like
they disappear from from in front of the
lens and suddenly you're
like what are they worth now you know
um we are much more more than our
careers we are so much more than our
careers we sell ourselves so short when
we settle into a job and say like this
is who I am right now and maybe someday
you know maybe we have a dream that
someday we'll be we'll we'll have an
identity that's a little bigger a little
bigger maybe I'll be a painter someday
I'll have my own gallery and that's what
I'll be we're more than that we are more
than our art we're more than our our our
our highest Ambitions for most creative
self like we are I think we Are
Spiritual Beings and that we should be
thinking about like higher minded things
you know that's what love is man it's
this thing that floats above the whole
world and says like how can I actually
serve this place in these people that
don't really want to be served and that
don't serve me you know and when we
start thinking that maybe that's who I
am my highest self is that guy oh so
hard to meet that person so hard to be
that person and so worth struggling to
be that hey guys I'm doing another live
podcast downtown LA at the Regent
Theater and my special guest for January
24th is Kristen Ritter Breaking Bad
Jessica Jones this is going to be a sold
out event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you with
Michael Rosen bomb with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so
excited